Apple tried to buy the Stargate
franchise more than once
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV a
movie channel
[Music]
[Music]
I know this was actually something I
heard quite a while ago but I never
really bothered telling anyone because
well I didn't think it was unimportant
but actually with news I'm going to tell
you about in the next video it's become
a little bit more important so let me
give you the background
Apple actually tried to buy MGM first
before Amazon even got involved in
buying MGM Apple did put an official bid
in the thing is that Amazon came in and
basically doubled it so Apple tried to
pay three to four billion region for the
MGM brand and IP whereas Amazon paid
well over eight now obviously the reason
why Apple did that and was trying to buy
MGM was because they desperately wanted
the IP they just undervalued it I would
argue that actually James Bond alone is
worth probably 2 billion so a four
billion dollar four to five billion
dollar bid I would say was horribly
undervaluing the MGM brand
apple as well as a subscription service
apple plus desperately need new content
they've been trying to get new content
for a long time now for them buying MGM
would have been very similar to what
Disney did when they bought Fox Disney
wanted to do a streaming platform they
realized that they didn't have enough
content on their own so they bought Fox
they brought all of that content
together and now Disney plus here in the
UK is probably the best streamer service
we get apple need to do the same
they need to buy IP now they can produce
new television they can produce new
movies
and they have been they've also bought
movies that maybe didn't go to cinema
for example there was the Tom Hanks
movie A couple of years ago called
Greyhound now it was about to be
released just before the pandemic they
realized a similar release wasn't any
good so Apple just went well we'll have
it and they just bought the movie and
put it on apple plus they've also
obviously had quite a few original
series very good ones as well
but buying something like MGM where you
then buy a massive catalog of back
products as well something that you can
immediately put onto apple plus but also
you've then got a massive back catalog
of Ip intellectual properties that you
can develop new projects from would have
been incredibly exciting and to be
honest would have meant that I'd have
subscribed to Apple which I don't
currently
now Amazon beaten to the punch and
Amazon are going to be able to take
advantage of all that IP I'm actually
told though that one of the things that
Apple were interested in just like
Amazon were was the Stargate franchise
because they desperately want a big
sci-fi franchise on Apple they are
currently desperately looking for
something and I can also tell you
exclusively that they have actually
spoken to Paramount about potentially
developing a Star Trek series on their
own now at the moment Alex kurtzman has
full control over Star Trek but
according to some sources that's
changing and that um Paramount are
really pulling away from Alex Goods when
they're trying to get Star Trek out of
his production company's hands they want
to go in a different direction now I did
a little video a little while ago about
selling Star Trek now that sounded a
little bit dramatic but basically all
Paramount are currently looking at doing
is reverting back to what they were
doing just a couple of years ago with
Star Trek and allowing other companies
to step in and produce the television
shows for Star Trek in cooperation with
Paramount instead of Paramount doing it
themselves and then those TV shows
worldwide appear on those other streamer
services for example Picard in the UK
was advertised as an Amazon production
um Discovery the first few series were
advertisers and Netflix production and
they were shown on those streaming
platforms
please like subscribe and hit the Bell
notification if you are new to the
channel so you don't miss any of our new
videos also if you really want to
support the channel consider hitting the
join button and you'll get all of our
Thursday videos 24 hours before anybody
else all of the links are in the
description
Apple wants to do the same they wanted
to produce their own Star Trek series
and put it on their streaming service
and it'd be an apple production
now I'm actually told they're still
looking at that and if it is true that
Star Trek is being pulled away because
Paramount plus is kind of failing and
Paramount plus worldwide might kind of
fizzle out a little bit then we might
actually get to see a Star Trek series
on Apple
but
they're also still interested in
Stargate and I hear that just a couple
of months ago
um in the end of August early September
Apple did actually approach Amazon and
asked them about taking on the Stargate
franchise
they wanted to basically rent it off MGM
produce the TV show and potentially
movies Etc themselves and put them on
Apple Plus making Stargate the big
sci-fi franchise for Apple
now at the moment Amazon wants Stargate
to be the big franchise for Amazon they
don't want to let it out but it is
interesting and it does support this
idea that actually Stargate is really
the sleeping giant of sci-fi that even
when they tried to buy the company and
it failed they still went after one of
the big franchises and were hopeful that
Amazon might actually let them have it
now I'm going to play a little bit of a
fantasy game now
how cool would it have been if Apple had
got hold of um Stargate I actually think
of Apple had bought MGM we'd probably
all be a lot happier right now because
out of all of these streaming services
the cash rich ones
are actually Amazon and apple but Apple
even dwarf Amazon
so Disney are actually having massive
financial problems at the moment they're
losing anything up to 500 million
dollars a quarter because of Disney plus
now I say they're losing money they're
choosing to spend that money and they're
not making it back obviously but they're
trying to make Disney plus the biggest
streaming service on the planet they're
trying to overtake Netflix they're
spending money to make money but they
are still losing money hand over fist
Amazon have actually had their own
financial difficulties during covid
their share price extensioner was
massively over inflated and because
everybody stayed at home we started
buying stuff off Amazon
um now there's been a correction and the
reality is set in and you know their
share prices drop quite dramatically and
they've also massively overspent on
projects like Lord of the Rings so
they're not as cash rich as they were
even though they do have the finances to
pretty much produce any TV show they
want
HBO is in massive financial problems and
they have huge debt Paramount owes
nearly 20 billion dollars again massive
debt and they actually are struggling to
pay it off
but apple on the other hand she was just
the first company to go through valuing
itself at three trillion dollars over
the last three or four years it's
tripled in value apple plus comes free
with almost every iPhone sold so and
that's the main way people subscribe
probably the most cash rich company on
the planet they can afford to spend
massive amounts of money on apple plus
if they choose to and they seem to be
gearing up in that direction obviously
they've produced some really impressive
television but they've never really had
that big signature TV show so kind of
like what Amazon tried to do with Lord
of the Rings and it kind of backfired on
them but Apple if they had got their
hands on Stargate
people would have followed that because
Stargate like Battlestar Galactic like
the expanse like
um Babylon 5 and shows like this that I
keep talking about they have really
loyal fan base people will subscribe to
Apple Plus just to watch that show like
people subscribe to Paramount plus just
to watch Star Trek I actually think it's
possibly a massive shame that Apple
didn't get its hands on this franchise
because I think potentially they could
have done something really exciting I
see what they did with Jason momoa's C
project for example and I just think
damn it they could have done something
really brilliant if they'd have got
Stargate onto that streaming service
but they didn't
but
and here's the big one now they're still
looking for that big sci-fi franchise it
looks like they might not get Star Trek
they're definitely not getting Stargate
but is there a possibility they could be
getting another big sci-fi franchise
that is currently off our screens that
we would love to see return well that's
going to be for the next video if you
are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification so
you don't miss any of our new videos
also if you want to become a fully
fledged side tracker and really support
the channel consider hitting the join
button where you get all of our Thursday
videos 24 hours before anybody else as
always please stay safe I'll see you
next time foreign
[Music]